the final Blitz for the only remaining
Senate midterm race in the nation the
hotly contested Georgia runoff incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock and
Republican Challenger Herschel Walker
are making last pitches their last
pitches to undecided voters while
Democrats have secured control of the
Senate with 50 seats a Warnock win would
solidify their majority in committees
but a walker Victory weakens the
Democrats grip on the upper chamber
Congressional correspondent Nicole
Killian is in Atlanta where both
candidates are pulling out all the stops
Nicole good morning
hey good morning to you Michelle and
make no mistake about it this runoff
election hasn't even gotten underway
it's officially next Tuesday but already
more than 1.8 million voters have cast
their ballots here in the peach state
and Georgia election officials say
yesterday Mark the single biggest day of
early voting ever
on the final day of early voting lines
wrapped around this Atlanta area polling
station Cindy Watts waited an hour and a
half casting her ballot for Senator
Rafael Warnock it was worth it I'm ready
for uh this to get behind us why do you
think it's worth it because democracy is
at stake and it's uh that's important
who did you support uh Herschel and why
Mr Walker lifelong Republican more than
anything
but I just I think no I think 50 50 uh
is far better than 5141 either way even
though control of the U.S Senate May no
longer be on the line the high stakes
runoff Drew high profile support this
week from President Biden who phoned
bank for Warnock in Boston you can't be
tired to former president Barack Obama
who made his second trip to the peach
state for the incumbent we can't rest on
our laurels
we it's way too early to do a happy
dance so what you need to do have 10 of
your friends every
nominee has pulled out his own star
surrogates including top Republican
Senators and Governor Brian Kemp that's
why we need personal Walker in the
United States Senate
but Walker has also continued to battle
new controversies from an ex-girlfriend
who told The Daily Beast he's unstable
to questions about his residency in
Georgia after tax records revealed he
declared Texas as his principal resident
no no no Georgia bread
and when I die I'll be joined today
because that's who I am
Lockhart's campaign has declined to
comment on some of those new reports the
former Georgia football star is expected
to tailgate with supporters later today
at the SEC Championship game here in
Atlanta while Senator Warnock will stump
with his fellow Georgia Senator John
ossoff at a rally tonight Dana
all right Nicole it feels like they've
been voting in Georgia non-stop I'm sure
they'll be happy once the election is
over we appreciate the update